SAAD ALI: All right,
name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software
engineer at Google,
here at KubeCon Seattle.
And now, I'm here
with Tim Hockin,
the granddaddy of Kubernetes.
He does not need
an introduction.
But for those of you
who don't know him,
he's been involved
with the project
from the very beginning.
And he's helped architect a
lot of the Kubernetes project.
So Tim, can you tell us a little
bit about those early days
and how the project
has evolved since then?
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
The early days was really about
bringing out some of the ideas
that we had in Borg,
taking some of the lessons
that we had learned
through Borg,
and bringing them out
to rest of the world.
We saw the Docker
thing happening.
And it was pretty exciting.
But we knew where
that road would go.
And we knew that something
like Borg would be needed.
So we wanted to take
the best lessons
that we had learned through
the Borg and Omega process
and share them with the world.
It was a lot of fun
to be able to do that.
And from then on, the community
has grown at this amazing pace.
We're here, standing among
8,000 of my best friends.
And it's a little overwhelming.
SAAD ALI: That it's awesome.
So what are some
of the challenges
that the community
is facing now?
As you said, it's grown
to a tremendous scale.
There are more
contributors now than ever.
How are we dealing with that?
And what are some of the
challenges that come with it?
TIM HOCKIN: We got a
bunch of challenges.
Some of them are, how
do we stay on track?
How do we not lose focus of the
core principles of the project?
We need to make sure that
we don't try to do too much.
We stay within our swim lane.
But we want to be sure to
empower other communities--
other projects.
Projects like Istio and Knative
are really interesting to me,
because they build
on top of Kubernetes.
You can see more and
more effort in Kubernetes
going into extensibility
and mechanisms around that.
There's a bunch of talks here
at KubeCon about extensibility.
So we're really leveraging that
to make sure the project stays
at a reasonable size.
The community
contributors, now, are
dealing with issues of
compatibility and growth
and scope.
Every new change has a chance to
break every one of these users.
And so we have to be more
careful than we've ever been.
SAAD ALI: And so, one of your
talks this week was about CRDs.
And that's one of the main
mechanisms for extensibility.
Can we deep dive into that a
little bit and get technical?
What are some of the
challenges with CRDs?
Why do they exist?
How should people use them?
Are they only for
external people?
Are they part of
the core project?
How does that work?
TIM HOCKIN: Thanks
for the lead-in.
This was my lightning
talk this week.
It was really about
the birth of CRDs,
Custom Resource
Definitions-- this is one
of our extensibility
mechanisms--
and how that's being
used in Kubernetes.
And it was one of
those things that
was surprising and emergent.
It's one of these things, if
you set out to do on purpose,
you probably would fail at.
But because it emerged
organically from the project,
it was really successful.
It's a way that people
are extending Kubernetes
to add their own types,
their own concepts,
into our API machinery.
It started off as a thing
for people to just prototype
and play with.
And it wasn't really very good.
It was very second-class.
But now, it's very much
a first-class thing.
We've been adding more and
more support for versioning
and schema and
validation, to the point
now that you can actually
build real things with it.
And I know you know
this, because we made you
and your SIG be one of
our pioneers, right?
SAAD ALI: Right.
TIM HOCKIN: And you guys, thanks
for falling on that grenade.
But like, some of the storage
work is happening as CRDs.
It is not just an extension.
It's actually built-in
as part of the system.
It's just a resource
definition that's not in code.
It's in declaration.
SAAD ALI: So what does that
mean for the built-in types?
Are there going to be
no more built-in types?
What does the future look like?
TIM HOCKIN: Well,
long-term, I would
like to see us with an empty API
server that's got nothing in it
except namespaces, custom
resource definitions, admission
control web hooks, and all the
stuff you need to run CRDs.
Everything else gets kicked
out-- pods, services,
deployments-- all get moved
out into custom resource
definitions.
And Kubernetes machinery
becomes a separate project.
And it's a thing that
you load type sets into.
And you go forward from there.
SAAD ALI: And so this
Kubernetes API Machinery
can then be utilized
by multiple projects.
It's not going to be
Kubernetes specific.
It could be used by Istio
and other projects as well.
TIM HOCKIN: Absolutely,
this is already happening.
But today, we're managing it
through several different forks
of the code base.
So we have a generic API
server and an example extension
server.
And we shouldn't need
to do those things.
They should all be
on the same basis.
SAAD ALI: Got it.
Let's talk about the
community a little bit.
The community, of course,
has grown tremendously
in the last few years.
How do we manage that?
What are some of the challenges
with a community of that scale?
And I know, you served on the
Steering Committee for a while.
Can you tell us what the
Steering Committee's view
on this is?
TIM HOCKIN: The
community is what
makes this project successful.
Unambiguously, that is what
makes it unique in the world.
And we need to make sure that
we make that healthy for people.
We have tens of thousands of
contributors at this point.
And honestly, the weak
spots that we have, I think,
are the same as a lot
of other projects.
It's things like
documentation and onboarding.
We're never going to be
quite good enough on that.
But we're spending a
lot of time and energy
trying to make
those things better.
We've got a whole SIG that is
just devoted to the contributor
experience and
making things better.
We had our Contributors'
Summit yesterday,
where we had
400-ish contributors
and would-be contributors here.
SAAD ALI: 500 on the wait list.
TIM HOCKIN: Yeah, and
more on the wait list.
They were here to talk
about how to contribute
to Kubernetes, what the
state of the project is.
So I think we need to make
sure that we are doing things
to make these people successful.
They are the way that
we are able to grow
at the rocket-ship growth
that we've been having.
SAAD ALI: And what are
some of those projects
that we're doing
to help continue
to sustain that growth?
TIM HOCKIN: We've got everything
from better documentation
and onboarding-- we had
a New Contributor track
at the Contributor Summit.
So this is for people
who are just starting out
with Kubernetes
to come and learn,
how does our code base work?
How do our bots--
all of the GitHub workflow
that we've built--
how do those things work?
We've also got people who
are building those bots.
We've got a group of people
we call EngProd at Google.
They're building these
things like robots
that make interacting with
GitHub a little smoother,
a little easier--
and scaling up a
little bit better.
Just among things, we've also
got all the documentation
people, which is serving
purposes both for end-users
and for new contributors.
SAAD ALI: In terms of leadership
in the community, what I've
noticed, as I talked to Ash
and Janet and other folks,
is that this community
really incubates new leaders.
Is that natural?
Is that something
that was intended?
And how does that happen?
And what are your
thoughts on that?
TIM HOCKIN: I take it as a
real compliment actually.
It's very intentional.
We know that projects
only survive as long
as their leadership survives.
And I know that I
won't be here forever.
I want this project to
be around a long time.
So I want to make
sure that there's
people who know
what they're doing,
who have some real battle scars,
who know where the bodies are
buried, who are coming
up through the ranks
to take over the project.
I think this is a
really important part
of the way the Steering
Committee is set up.
We set it up in a way
that, all the people
who originated the project--
only a few of us can possibly
be on Steering Committee
after the end of this year.
And I think it's
really important,
so that we've got
fresh blood coming in,
fresh eyes, fresh perspectives.
SAAD ALI: Awesome.
So let's switch gears a little
bit and talk about KubeCon.
This is probably your--
what?-- sixth KubeCon?
TIM HOCKIN: Worldwide-- yeah.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, so can you talk
about what changes you've seen
and what you're looking
forward to this week?
TIM HOCKIN: Well,
the first KubeCon
was 400 and something people.
So we're roughly 20 times
bigger than that this time,
so it's a little bit
of a different thing.
But at the same time, I walk
around the show floor here,
and I'm constantly seeing
people that I know-- people
I've worked with on the
project, ex-Googlers,
people I worked with at other
companies, friends of friends.
It's amazing.
It really is like hanging out
with 8,000 of my best buddies.
Went to the party last night--
there was a reception last
night--
and just hung out with
people and just talked.
And sometimes, we
talked about Kubernetes.
And sometimes, we talked
about other stuff.
And it's really awesome.
It's a little
overwhelming, honestly.
The keynote room
is pretty massive.
But it's amazing that
these people are all here
to talk about this
thing that is making,
hopefully, their lives
a little bit better.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, that's awesome.
Last question-- put
you on the spot.
What is your favorite
KubeCon memory?
TIM HOCKIN: My favorite
KubeCon memory--
boy-- probably the first
KubeCon at this hotel
in San Francisco, where it was
amazing to see 400 people here
to talk about this thing.
And they were all
early adopters,
the people who had actually
been using the system
and playing with it.
And I knew almost everybody.
And Brian, Clayton, and
I sequestered ourselves
in a back room and put up on
the whiteboard out in the lobby,
come to room whatever and get
your PRs shot down in person.
And we had a line of
people who were there
to get their PRs live-reviewed.
SAAD ALI: Nice, we
can try that again
and see how long that line is.
All right, thank
you very much, Tim.
TIM HOCKIN: Thanks, Saad.
SAAD ALI: It was a
pleasure talking to you.
Take care.
TIM HOCKIN: You too.
[MUSICAL JINGLE]